president biden says the buck stops with
him but the guy just can't stop blaming
others for his own mistakes a defensive
president keeps passing the blame for
the complete taliban takeover of
afghanistan biden trying to throw the
intelligence community under the bus
there was no consensus you go back and
look at the intelligence reports they
said that it was like more likely to be
sometime by the end of the year your top
military advisors warned against
withdrawing on this timeline they wanted
you to keep about 2500 troops no they
didn't it was split that wasn't true
that wasn't true so no one no one told
your military advisor did not tell you
no we should just keep 2500 troops it's
been a stable situation for the last
several years we can do that we can
continue to do that no no one said that
to me that i can recall
so that's three different answers he's
given right dana he said it in the uh a
question and answer session last month
no then he said it was split and then
again he said no
what did he add at the end of the last
one which is not that i recall not that
i recall and that is a way to one i mean
that could be the case i'm sure he gets
a lot of briefings but we know that back
in april in the white house briefing
room they said that the military
suggested this and we knew this because
it was on the front page of every paper
right i mean if you read any any of the
news it was there we covered it at the
time as we're following the story and it
certainly it's a fact that intelligence
reports are a judgment call it's this is
our best assessment this is what we have
right now but the reason that a
commander-in-chief is there is because
you get to make the decision you have to
make the decision that is a
decision-making job so the decision does
rest with him and i think that when you
have tension between an intelligence
community and a president that's never
good for anybody
and president trump former president
trump
he came out and had a statement that
said basically you get the equipment out
then you get the interpreters out then
you get the people out and the last
people that come out are the military
biden did it in reverse right uh it
seems like when biden talks about this
he
at least believes he's being truthful
he's wanted the troops out he was
focused on the troop level because that
was going to be the political win right
if we get he got him down to a few
hundred right and so he was going to
take him down originally the date was 9
11 and that was just well appalling so
they moved it up to late august but he
was most focused so you take the troops
out which is and i talked to somebody
about this today
common sense says you get the civilians
out including the afghan allies then the
diplomats and the last people to leave
are your military or the people on the
ground and in terms of the intelligence
couldn't joe biden use a like a laptop
from hunter to pop up now or uh
you know crack sex tape to show up but
see the intel community's turned against
him so i guess that won't just appear
out of nowhere so real though they're
going to have hearings on this they're
saying in september and they're going to
have people testifying from the
intelligence community you know what did
you know when did you know it what did
you tell the president they're going to
subpoena documents how's that going to
shake out
well
you know dana knows government much
better than i that's not necessary no i
i believe that i really respect you
because you have a depth of knowledge
that i i have a kind of a superficial
knowledge wait a second but did geraldo
just say somebody does something better
than him i don't know why i've got
there's a button i got a million i got a
million yards we got we're gonna have to
shut down this show
this is bigger this is bigger than
watergate i i think that the
intelligence community is full of crap i
think they're totally self-inflated i
think they're the most important people
in washington they go around strutting
around oh i know i get this and i
anytime i see them overseas they don't
know
they're cocktail people they're
chartered jet people they're not they
they're not the grunty people they got
those some of bin laden in the in the in
the movies i i just think that uh this
those people were advising and they and
they they they're you know what they do
best leak so they're great
they're great
but they see way but but i have to just
give you one factoid right now
the banks in afghanistan are empty
there's not a dime left they robbed
everything the united states has cut off
all credit to afghanistan nobody's
picking up the garbage the lights are
going to go out soon that are still that
are still burning the water is not going
to be working in a in a little bit those
cell phones they all treasure the cell
towers are going to go down
the the reason the taliban is playing
ball right now is they know they have
not
a chance in in shinola to get that fixed
without a whole lot of help and if they
don't play ball and let these people out
you know i'm not saying anything i'm not
trying to
justify the mistakes that were made by
us but i believe that this situation
while not redeemable we're not going to
ever go back to afghanistan we do have
some leverage right now to have a humane
evacuation but i think america has to
come to grips with the fact that we're
going to have tens of thousands of
afghans coming to america
get over it
we're going to absorb we're basically
paying all these people to come out
that's what's happening well and then
and then when it's done china and
pakistan are going to swoop in with the
cash correct the um
anytime you you decide you're going to
leave that's sending a signal no matter
what so
i find the
the the worst thing that biden is doing
is blaming the afghan army and saying
that they didn't fight as hard because
if you know that the exit's coming and
everybody apparently knew this was
coming
they also knew that the taliban was
going to
become the new boss so why tangle with
the new landlord if you know that you're
not going to get air power and you know
the united states is leaving
it seems that the fast transition that
the afghan army was allowing was just
them looking out for their self-interest
it's like what like why fight why go
down with the ship right if the ship why
don't i just you know i don't want them
to kill my family so we'll just let them
in they made deals i think in terms of
accountability they have we have to go
further back there were so i mean i mean
again i would say it's on my head i take
responsibility for ignoring certain
things and i you know i ignored claims
of well-documented uh uh stories about
fraud and misuse of funds because it
wasn't like it was afghanistan it was so
confusing and blah blah blah it was
maybe it was just part of anti-war
assumptions that i thought were silly
but they ended up being right you're
talking like 600 billion dollars lost in
grifting and corruption out of if out of
a war that cost over a trillion that
needs to be looked at where did this
money go who may who wanted this war to
keep going to make money i think is a
really good thing and lastly just a
recommendation for a movie one of the
best war movies is an afghanistan movie
called the beast i don't know if
anybody's seen it but it's probably
around
her
i never saw that i don't know
the book's better than the movie geraldo
right dana
i was actually just gonna say that's
right dana and i know hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else